amazon's not rocket science it's a 24 7  store with cheap prices and immediate  delivery on amazon ain't even amazon i  ordered something one time from amazon  it showed up in a walmart box yeah was  that genius i think so let's see it's  genius execution especially at that size  it's genius and recruiting talent  because bezos isn't building amazon  healing the people who build the teams  who build amazon continuing to move up  from the scale of leverage per unit of  time so they've just figured out how to  get the most return on their time by  using every form of leverage that we  have what do you think the most  ingenious invention of all time has been  my favorite one is air conditioning